bien sûr que j'ai peur parce que comme
vous le savez je sais pas si vous
connaissez le 8e arrondissement c'est
ton appel le poumon économique de la
capitale il y a 37000 habitants 200000
personnes viennent y travailler chaque
jour vous pensez bien que les
commerçants les restaurateurs tout le
monde a peur et aussi les riverains
parce que j'ai quand même des habitants
les gens ne le savent pas sur l'avenue
il y a peut-être une vingtaine mais
derrière toutes ces rues avec les écoles
et tout ça donc j'ai des habitants et
ils ont tous peur de ce qui va se passer
et j'ai retraduit effectivement leur
peur donc pour pour mercredi on espère
tous que les choses vont bien se passer
et qu'il n'y aura pas de débordement
parce que vous le savez certainement en
98 vous savez qu'en 98 il y a une
voiture une une personne dans la voiture
elle a paniqué et elle a paniqué et elle
a foncé 150 personnes blessées dont deux
morts donc c'est pour éviter ce genre de
choses que je demande premièrement qu'on
interdise la circulation entre
les arrivées sur l'avenue voilà on
filtre les arrivées sur Champs-Élysées
pour empêcher que certains casseurs il
faut dire les choses que certains
casseurs arrivent avec les mortiers
parce que quand vous venez fêter une
victoire vous venez pas avec des
mortiers ni avec des bars et tout ça
voilà donc on va voir ce qui s'est passé
déjà samedi soir et vous allez me dire
ce que vous craignez pour mercredi c'est
vrai que voilà c'est Gilles tu vas nous
dire ce que tu en penses aussi avec
plaisir je rigolais
[Applaudissements]
et qui dit fait dit parfois débordement
et c'est regarder sur les Champs-Élysées
et vous craignez pire mercredi c'est ça
on va voir ce qui s'est passé rien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est beaucoup tout dépend si c'est le
million qui arrive
pas
qu'est-ce que vous disiez Mathieu
ils attendaient et Madame me disait
environ à peu près 2000 CRS ce qui est
pas énorme s'ils sont un million ils
seront devant 1200 samedi
je crains si jamais on n'arrive pas à
interdire les access sera difficile à
gérer pour les forces de l'ordre alors
vous créez c'est ce que vous craignez
mercredi Gilles tous les incidents
évidemment ce qu'on voit c'est
regrettable madame la mer mais très
franchement le bilan de la fête après la
victoire du Maroc c'est effectivement
quelques tirs de mortier inacceptables
et trois scooters incendiés de deux
vitrines brisées c'est quand même
majoritairement une belle fête qui s'est
passé et la joie des Marocains était
communicative c'est parce que je veux
défendre c'est parce que je veux
défendre les les les supporters les
personnes qui viennent
fêter la victoire que j'essaie de
demander qui est des mesures
supplémentaires pour éviter des
débordements sauf quand vous parlez de
guerre civile là je trouve que le mot
n'est pas approprié s'il y a des
débordements ce sera sans doute des
Black Blocs mais ça n'a rien à voir avec
les Marocains madame j'en sais rien
pardon mais jusqu'à maintenant regarder
en 2018 quand
suite à la Coupe du monde ils sont
arrivés ils sont quand même rentrés donc
au drogstore ils ont pillé ils ont cassé
le drugstore publicity sur les
Champs-Élysées cinq fois ils ont refait
les vitrines donc un moment entre les
gilets jaunes et tout ce qui se passe
avec à chaque victoire de coupe du monde
je parle pas simplement marocain à
chaque fois quand il y a un
rassemblement sur les Champs-Élysées
c'est le binz la dernière fois quand ils
sont montés sur une voiture de
sentinelle de sentinelle qu'ils ont
secoué les sentinelles les mecs ils sont
quand même armés à l'intérieur
heureusement qu'ils ont heureusement ils
avaient donc la maîtrise voilà donc mais
autrement il serait descendu ça aurait
été voilà une cata c'est pour cela que
je demande qu'on protège l'avenue des
Champs-Élysées et le périmètre parce que
il y a des habitants ils n'en peuvent
plus d'avoir des gaz lacrymogènes il
n'en peut plus d'avoir des klaxons à 2h
du matin ça n'arrêtait pas mais surtout
il ne respecte pas les feux rouges et
ouais en fait Géraldine la mère disait
qu'elle avait peur que ce soit le small
mais moi je vous écoute et je trouve
extrêmement juste et pertinente en fait
moi je trouve que c'est normal que vous
ayez envie de protéger et les riverains
et vous administrez moi je vois pas du
tout il y a rien de stigmatisant il y a
rien de problématique j'entends déjà mon
procès à gauche de limite ses racistes
de dire ça ben en fait non mais vu la
tranche que j'ai on peut pas dire
tout à l'heure elle a dit à chaque fois
qu'il y a des manifestations sur les
Champs-Élysées voilà c'est elle parle ni
du Maroc voilà donc c'est bien de le
préciser c'est voilà si demain voilà et
c'est vrai que mais je pense qu'il faut
quand même je me rappelle encore et je
le redis les Anglais au Stade de France
Mokhtar était là voilà
voilà oui non mais il faut pas non plus
laisser ce discours pardon et ce débat à
l'extrême droite ou à Zemmour on a le
droit de dire aussi que peut-être lors
de ce match là à la fin il y aura des
affrontements parce que c'est pas un
masque c'est pas un match comme les
autres ce sera peut-être pas que des
casseurs parce que quand il y a des
matchs France Algérie ou France -
Tunisie ou France - Maroc et bah ça se
passe pas toujours bien on siffle et
tout ça oui mais sauf que là en
l'occurrence c'était pas les Anglais
c'était c'était malheureusement les
Français qui ont passé les Anglais
il a compris que il comprenait rien a
toujours dit que c'était évidemment les
français pour massacrer les Anglais et
les et les Espagnols les Anglais mais
parce qu'elle a avec ça mais là moi j'ai
deux fois du pudding alors moi
trois fois Bertrand Dicaire cette croix
je crois qu'elle est petite copine avec
le roi Charles news
avec le gars de la buffet du PSG on
descendez oui qu'est-ce qu'il veut non
mais madame moi c'est guerre civile qui
me gêne
non mais non mais tu avais raison mais
non mais non mais non parce que quand
Géraldine dit peut-être que ce ne sont
pas des Black Blocs peut-être des
Marocains sous-entend Géraldine vous
sous-entendez que c'est parce qu'ils
sont marocains ou parce qu'ils auraient
peut-être avec ça
elle peut préciser voilà parce qu'elle a
dit quand il y a des matchs chez
aucun chez les Français arrêté tout le
temps en fait toi tu as un côté mais
insupportable
pour l'expliquer agile mais je voulais
dire qu'il pouvait y avoir des
échauffourés il pouvait y avoir de
délinquance partout et ça pouvait mal se
passer de du côté marocain et du côté
français voilà c'est tout il y a pas de
problème il y a pas une stigmatisation
des Marocains ou une stigmate sauf que
c'est bien de le préciser quand même
Géraldine parce que si tu fais jette un
petit peu sur les réseaux sociaux il y a
quand même une montée de tweet raciste
on peut pas aimer le Maroc et en même
temps aimer la France et cetera il y a
quand même une petite montée
bien sûr ma mère elle est au Maroc donc
j'adore le Maroc donc c'est peut-être
même plus pour le moment Tunisie et il
est il explique il a il a plein d'amis à
Rabat
moi j'adore les olives
[Applaudissements]
depuis depuis qu'ils ont gagné contre le
Portugal ils sont en 2009 il y a que des
gars qui ont des origines marocaines je
vois des gars salut contrôle non mais tu
sais que mon père a vécu 3 ans sur
Ouarzazate
tout le monde est marocain c'est un truc
de fou là avec des marocain partout